Okay Michael you got answers for me?
>> Think so.
>> Okay good. Alright so let's look at the first one.
Mutually orthogonal. Does that apply to PCA, ICA, both, or neither?
>> So, it was one of the defining properties in PCA, so I would say PCA.
>> Okay that's fair enough. That is actually correct. What about ICA?
>> I don't, I don't know. It's not one of
the defining features. It wasn't, it wasn't even thinking about orthugonality.
>> That's right. And in fact ICA by finding independent.
Projections are almost all but guaranteed to find ones that are not mutually
arthugoial, it doesn't care at all. So in fact this is what makes PCA
a global algorithm since it has
this global constraint of mutual arthugoality. Where
ICA really in its definition that cares about that, so this should be unchecked.
>> Okay.
>> I'm going to put an X there to represent unchecked. Okay, got it?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. What about mutually independent?
>> So,
that was how ICA was trying to construct its, I don't
want to say features, yeah I guess the, the transformed features.
>> That's right.
>> It was trying to create them to
be mutually independent, so I would check ICA in
that case. And, PCA didn't use that language
at all, so I would just not do that.
>> Okay. That's fair. I will point out though,
that it turns out that PCA is trying to do
something that sometimes will create things that are mutually independent.
But we'll see that when we answer the next question.
But you're right, PCA does not care about mutually
independents. Okay, what about the third phrase, maximal variance?
>> Alright. Again, I feel like this was one of the defining
features of PCA. So it was trying to choose dimensions that maximize variance.
>> That's right, and what about ICA?
>> In terms of variance? Again, the, the,
there, it wasn't really discussed in that context.
>> Right. ICA is specifically interested
in notions of independence, statistical independence. Not inpu,
not in issues of varience. So in fact
ICA does not care about maximizing varients. Now
that we have gotten this far let me point
something out, it turns out that because of
this arthugonal deconstraint this lack of independent contraint,
but this gold and maximizing varience, there are
cases under which PCA happens to find independent projections.
What's really going on here with these three constraints
or, or lack of at least one in this
case, is that PCA is tending to find things
that are uncorrelated. By maximizing variance along arthogonal dimensions is
finding uncorrelated dimensions. And that makes some sens given
what it's trying to do. But that is not the
same thing as finding things that are statistically independent.
Again there is this particular case, there is a specific
case where that does work out, and that's
when all of your data is in fact Gaussian.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> And why Gaussian? Because it
turns out that the distribution that maximizes
variance is in fact the normal
distribution. That's my interpretation of a normal
distribution. So maximizing variance means that what PCA is doing is it's trying
to find a bunch of orthogonal Gaussians. More or less. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah
but, you were saying that it, and it aligns with ICA in that case?
>> In that case yes, because it turns out that uncorrelated ends up being
independent under very specific distributions. But that's
a coincidence it's not a normal fact.
>> Ha, ha.
>> But by the way this, this is probably worth
pointing out here something that at least I think is
kind of interesting here. Which is since ICA is only
trying to find things that are. Independent of one another.
Here's our little symbol for independence. As opposed
to things that are uncorrelated, things that are
[INAUDIBLE], it turns out that whatever it is
PCA is doing, it is not working under
the same underlying model as ICA. let's think about what ICA is trying to do. ICA
is trying to find a bunch of these
prjections all of which are statically independnet. RIght?
>> Mm-hm.
>> What happens if I take a whole bunch of statically
independent variables and I add them together? In other words
I create linear combination of them. What am I going to
>> get? A bunch of sums of things that are
independent? Right and what does that tend towards in the limit?
>> I want to say that the law of large numbers tells us that it turns normal.
>> That's exactly right. If I take a bunch of independent variables and
I sum them together, that is, I create a linear combination, I in fact
end up with a gouache. And that is
the central limit theorem. So one argument you might
make is that if you believe in a
world where there are independent causes giving rise to
observables, which is what ICA believes, then whatever
you do, you should not be maximizing variance, becasue
you're guaranting the summing together otherwise independant variables.
Oh, I see. I see, I see. So by
trying to find things that are maximal variants it's trying to
mix together through the central unit theorem all these things that
are independent, so it's, it's, it's, it's, specifically not teasing apart
the independent things, it's trying to smush together the independent things.
>> Right. Under certain assumptions
about the distributions of these individual
variables. So another assumption that I see us making is not just
that these variables are independent, but that they are hightly non-normally
distributed. And if that's the case, then ending up with things that
look like gaussians, has got to be exactly the wrong thing to do.
If that assumption holds to be
true. Okay. What about maximum mutual information?
>> My understanding of what you describe for ICA said that this is
what it's trying to do. It's trying to find a new feature space
where the features are maximally. The
mutual information between them is large as
possible. So I would check the ICA in that case and not the PCA.
>> Let
me be Let me clarify soething you said. How can it be trying to
maximize mutual information while also trying to
make things that are mutually independent. I
think you would describe them both in the same language. So what is it
trying to make mutual independent? Different features.
The, the new, the new transform features.
>> Right. So each of the new transform features is independent with all the
other new transform features. So what is
it trying to maximize mutual information between?
>> Oh, the, I see. The the information that
content of the original features and the new features.
>> Right. So this is about joint mutual information between
all the original features together and All of the transform features.
There it's trying to maximize mutual information. But inside the
new transform features it's trying to make them pair-wise mutually independent.
>> Alright. I think I said that wrong because I understood
it wrong. So thank you for clarifying.
>> You're welcome. But now you understand it right.
>> Maybe.
>> Okay, let's go with that because
you got the checkmark right. What about PCA?
>> Just X that. I don't understand what that would mean.
>> Right. So if I were to put something here that it
could get a check mark for, what I put down is maximal reconstruction.
>> right.
>> Right. And notice that maximal reconstruction of your
original data is not the same thing as maximizing
mutual information. Thought of course in the limit they work out to be the same.
>> Interesting, okay.
>> But the one project that maximizes variance is not
necessarily the same as the first projection you find for
maximizing mutual information. So these things really are doing two
completely different things. Okay, last two what about ordered features?
>> So, in PCA, it was actually assigning, you know,
taking the maximum variant to dimension first and then the next,
>> Mm-hm
>> You know, after that's been subtracted out, whatever
has the largest remaining variance and so forth. So
that the features end up coming out in, in
a very specific order. And it has the property that
you could drop the, the last group of features
if you want to still have as high a
reconstruction area as possible, given the number of features
that you keep. So I would check PCA for that.
>> Okay, good. What about ICA?
>> You didn't say anything about the ordering or
how you'd actually find features. It seemed like in the
blind source separation example you gave It just, came
out with the three, so I'm going to say not ordered.
>> That's right and in fact, if you
think about the blind source separation example, how
in the world would you order people anyway.
I mean, other than in the obvious way.
It just doesn't really mean anything. I say it doesn't
have a notion of causes being more important than other
causes merely that they're independent. So, it doesn't really worry
about ordered features. It turns out in practice That you
can actually try to order the features by using something
called kertosis. Which is the fourth central moment of a
distribution. But that's really just something that's useful in some
specific cases, almost by coincidence. ICA, itself, does not particularly
care, about ordering. At least not classical ICA.
Okay, what about the last one, bag of features?
>> So, I. Would view what you just said about ICA as implying that
what ICA produces is a bag of features. There's no particular ordering to them.
>> That's right.
>> It's just a collection of things that
make up the whole. I guess, you know,
PCA, after you've thrown away whichever features you
don't want. The features that remains are just features.
They could be treated as a bag, I guess. So I don't know if
I would check that or not. I. For symmetry I guess I would say not.
>> Okay, but I'm going to say yes because
in ordered set of features is still a
bag of features. But we would accept either.
Either a check or an x, both are sort
of fine. So then, what do we really learn from this, Michael? I think what we've
learned is these things have fundamentally different assumptions
and are really trying to do completely different things.
>> Okay.
>> The
only thing they have in common is that
they're still trying to capture the original data somehow.
>> Alright. I understand that, but I also learned the opposite, which is
that they are really closely related and are trying to do very similar things.
>> Yeah. But their underlying models
are different. So maybe that, that's actually
a good point, Michael. So maybe a better way of saying it is,
their sort of fundamental assumptions are
different. Even though they're trying to do
the same thing, which is capture the original data in some new transform space
that is somehow better. But if you think about it that way, there
are two different optimization functions, two different
fitness functions, two different cost functions. So
even though they're trying to do
the same thing. Reconstructing. Keeping the data
around. Their basic assumptions about the way
that data is constructed is very different.
>> Okay.